Hillary Clinton have you heard of this
lady she just joined her I guess she was
on Twitter but she has activated her
Twitter account she also got verified
with in like an hour which took me I
don't tell you what I did to get it
anyway she is on Twitter let's look at
her bio and break it down for you at
Hillary Clinton wife mom lawyer women &
kids advocate floor which one what is
that what does that stand for for
arkansas AR Kait guy thank you FLOTUS
first lady the United States US senator
Secretary of State author dog owner hair
icon pantsuit aficionado glass ceiling
cracker TBD and I think we're gonna
start with the TBD thing because that's
what everybody's talking about is hilly
is it already preordained is Hillary
Clinton the next president of the United
States David oh no Hillary Clinton is
not the next president of the United
States why not everybody's no no no
black no I'm pretty sure it's gonna be a
former governor of Minnesota Jesse
Ventura oh you're going to crazy ah he's
got a conspiracy theory for everything
he won't let this NSA you know when you
know happened yeah he'll make sure that
nothing crazy goes undetected Howard
Stern will be his vice president he
literally said that he was yeah that he
wants to run and have her a ticket I run
III go with that ticket I reversing
Stern and inventor no not a good idea
like a California gubernatorial race
remember we just we had which talking
about Willis with Gary Coleman running
and horns as a porn star that's just
insane yeah Hillary what do you think
you know um I thought TVD meant the best
dancer I'm so confused and I seen her
break it down a bit and pop lock have
you seen her Harlem shake bill has an
office up in Harlem don't think she
hasn't done a little bit of shake enough
Aaron see her twerking yes
booty ah young she drops it like it's
very lukewarm you know I I say why not I
think she absolutely could run yeah
absolutely but she has to clear up this
Benghazi scandal first hey this is
approximately man it's ridiculous enough
enough I so as far as why not it seems
to me that like I've said this on the
show before but you know we left England
a long time ago because we didn't want
you know like one or two families
running everything all the time and if
we were to go from Clinton then we had a
couple bushes back to Clinton back to
Bush back to clinton and there's already
another bush you know George P bush
who's part latino and good looking so
they're very excited about him for like
20 20 it's like don't we need to escape
having these families that just run the
show yes another bush would be awful
because the first two they didn't have a
great track record right but under
Clinton we had we had we had good times
so you're willing we had a good time so
I would say hey okay let's go with that
again although I think it would be a
completely different administration it's
a completely different country that was
20 years ago you know we would I don't
think it would be the same Clinton yeah
and it's a woman you know I think it
would be completely different whereas
George senior george w George Latino you
know I mean it would be kind of the same
thing just a different palette of it
yeah I've been the same color scheme of
mood so I would not be for that yeah
well I am with you at least that the
Clintons deserve a little more credit
certainly the bushes what do you think
this idea that we they all have to be
celebrities cuz Hillary's basically a
celebrity at this point more than a
politician I'm just looking forward to
the Saturday Night Live sketches that
will come out of all this I mean another
bush yeah or another Clinton yeah in in
office uh for me yeah does the president
even really run the country so I think
you need to have a good looking
celebrity to run things to at least be
the face of the country and then have a
team of writers that actually you know
manipulate what happened right well I
don't know if the president runs things
cuz you know Obama said that you know
the buck stops with me which every
president says
all this stuff keeps coming up with the
NSA and IRS ababa and it's always well
low-level employees are running the
whole thing he's the president after
that you know get to him well looks the
IRS nothing to do with Obama right you
don't think he was sitting in an office
really highly doubt it right the IRS
scandal that they're trying to make it
seem like is because these these folks
the spine that happen to be tea party
you know corporations we're not doing
that their due diligence on the
paperwork that they filled out all right
if you're going to get money and you're
going to you're going to go start doing
political stuff with it and not help the
community which is what they were filing
under you're going to get red-flagged
that's all it is so that nothing to do
with the aisle are saying it's a red
flag when an organization that says they
don't want to pay taxes is actually
looked at right it seems like yeah yeah
that's all this stuff all these scammers
that are coming up for Obama have really
nothing to do with Obama yeah I mean
they really don't they are just under
his administration so it makes them look
bad but back to the Hillary thing really
quickly if we had a Hillary president
right let's say for eight years whatever
and then Chelsea you want it to run then
I'd be like you guys give someone else a
turn like I have a two-year-old right
and we're always like share you don't
mean like you had your turn now let's
share let's share the country with other
wealthy families yeah do you think maybe
we need a little bit of what most of the
world has or at least Europe where they
have either royalty or they have a
president who sort of ceremonial and
then a prime minister like we're trying
to get it all out in one guy which i
think is part of the problem like we
can't expect Obama to actually govern
and be the biggest superstar on the
planet what do you think split it up
into a president who's just like the
party guy and the prime minister who you
know does the work I still can't get
over the fact that Hillary's got 400,000
Twitter followers and learn one day I
know I mean I've been on for four years
I haven't even cracked 20,000 yet it's
the Clinton name that's the point yeah
you need to change it is a royal name
yeah yeah it is a royal Tanner you you
almost want you root for them yeah it's
very royal
you